en Afrique on vous appelle le Bruce Lee
africain en Chine vous êtes l'Aigle noir
et en France on vous a surnommé le
chinois noir alors vous êtes né petit
fils d'un roi tribal au fin fond du
Cameroun et vous êtes devenu à 25 ans le
premier moine Shaolin noir vous nous
raconterez votre histoire à 20h ça vaut
le coup
[Musique]
Dominique sattenang rebonsoir
vous êtes né le 14 janvier
1975 à Chang au Cameroun votre père est
ingénieur pour le ministère de
l'Agriculture et votre mère est fille du
roi de Bafou tout à fait vous êtes donc
Dominique le prince héritier de votre
tribu
pourtant vous ne portez pas le même nom
que vos frères et sœurs c'est dans un
rêve que votre mère s'est vu demander de
vous appeler sainte-hénangues celui qui
s'impose avant de s'installer alors ce
qui est incroyable dans cette histoire
c'est que en chinois ça fait l'anxiété
le moment calme c'est incroyable déjà
dès le départ espèce de dualité
africano chinoise alors vous grandissez
à Bafou et vers six ans vous vous mettez
à fabriquer des tables et des chaises en
bambou et j'allais les vendre à la Chang
à 25 km de Bafou c'est incroyable et pas
en 25 km vous portez sur votre tête les
chaises et les tables alors vous êtes
également très bon footballeur
votre grand-père voit en vous
de nouveaux rejet Milla footballeur
africain du siècle des siècle alors on
vous envoie dans la capitale économique
du Cameroun qui est Douala un vrai
capital s'il Yaoundé et là vous allez
faire le collège et le football et
là-bas donc à Douala est accueilli par
votre oncle alors lui il pratique les
arts martiaux et le premier jour le jour
où vous arrivez il vous emmène au cinéma
voir Opération Dragon avec Bruce Lee et
vous dormez pas de la nuit quoi c'est un
choc incroyable pour vous je me voyais
dans le film je me voyais à la place de
Bruce Lee et je fais comprendre le
lendemain que on devait aller à l'école
de football je lui ai dit une partais
pas et que je devais changer il me
fallait à tout prix faire des arts
martiaux et votre oncle est inquiet
parce que il dit que vont dire les
parents d'ailleurs votre père commence
par refuser et votre père dit bon écoute
si au premier trimestre il a des bonnes
notes à l'école ok il pourra faire son
truc de kung fu vous vous gagner de la
classe
et quand votre famille déménage au Gabon
à Libreville vous continuez le Kung Fu
envers et contre tout et un jour c'est
incroyable destin de ce mec un jour
faites un run dans un parc vous tombez
sur un chinois qui est en train de faire
des exercices de kung-fu à Libreville en
fait quand je m'approche vers ces
derniers je lui dis bonjour en français
il me répond pas en anglais il me répond
pas et à l'époque on croyait au fait que
tous les Chinois étaient forts alors si
je m'abonne vers lui je lui fais les
signes que j'ai envie d'apprendre il va
croire peut-être que j'ai envie de lui
boxer il va me il va me tabasser donc
évidemment il y avait cette peur et je
me suis bien mise à genoux et je lui ai
fait signe que je voulais apprendre il
est venu me lever il a écrit par tes
5h30
tous les matins et donc pendant un an et
demi à partir de là vous allez vous
rendre au parc tous les matins à 5h30
pour suivre l'enseignement de ce Chinois
c'est vraiment une prédestination comme
jamais vu rarement un jour vous blessez
au genou vous allez voir un acupuncteur
asiatique qui s'appelle wangpang et en
fait c'est acupuncteur et vice champion
de Chine de kung-fu d'une rencontre
majeure oui tout à fait c'est que
j'arrive il me demande comment je me
suis fait mal au genou je lui fais
comprendre c'était en train de en
faisant les exercices de kung-fu donc le
wius était supprimé demande comment
est-ce que j'arrive à faire ça avec qui
j'ai appris je lui raconte mon histoire
il me dit non lui-même il est vice
champion de Chine de kung-fu et en ce
moment on se met à deux au fond de
l'association gabonaise de kung-fu
incroyable alors là vous gravissez tous
les deux rapidement les échelons de la
célébrité locale et un jour vous
retrouvez devant le président Bongo
président du Gabon accompagné de
l'ambassadeur de Chine et donc vous
faciliter disons un accord entre la
Chine et le Gabon et pour vous remercier
l'ambassadeur de Chine nous demande ce
que vous voulez et vous lui répondez
découvrez le berceau du kung-fu le
temple de Shaolin le César de votre vie
futur et voilà comment en 1999 à l'âge
de 24 ans vous envolez pour la Chine
pour le mythique monastère fondée au 8e
siècle donc sur le mont song le temple
de Shaolin qui est un endroit
culte sauf qu'en arrivant c'est la
déception
vous retrouvez dans l'une des 1200
écoles qui pullulent autour du temple de
charme vous flippez vous dites je vais
jamais y arriver et là
le destin va encore frapper un jour le
grand maître Chillon c'est vraiment le
top c'est l'équivalent du dalaï-lama
alors il y a un festival international
de Shaolin il apparaît il vous remarque
il vous fait venir vous approchez là
c'est comme dans un film de Hollywood
qui vous approchez la sécurité vous
tombe dessus vous colle au sol il y
avait une barrière évidemment j'ai sauté
la barrière parce que quand il m'a fait
signe c'était pour moi un rêve
incroyable donc je saute la barrière
pour aller vers lui et donc la police
qui avait de retourner qui n'ont pas vu
le signe de du grand maître de mon
plateau au sol et mets un plaquée au sol
donc ça garde rapprocher venu demander
que qu'on me laisse que c'est le chef
spirituel qui me faisait appel là vous
êtes le premier étranger accepter comme
disciple vous êtes invité pour 6 mois et
vous allez y rester quatre ans quatre
ans dans le temple de Shaolin alors là
je dis tout de suite le programme c'est
très spartiate
réveil 4h30 du matin
ensuite à 5h prière bouddhiste pour la
paix du monde
ensuite petit déjeuner régime végétalien
pas d'oeuf rien non juste des légumes
et là pendant 10 heures exercices dans
une température qui entre 0 et 5 degrés
10h exemple d'exercice 6h30
grimper en courant les 5600 marches du
Mont song redescendre à quatre pattes et
parfois
vous montez avec une personne sur le dos
ou un seau d'eau dans chaque main
Dominique comment vous avez pu résister
à ça
en fait je pense aussi d'autre part
l'envie et
cette volonté détermination de ne pas
décevoir mes parents parce que ce que
mes parents attendaient de moi se disent
attendez de voir un footballeur de
demain donc pour moi c'était un défi un
challenge de pouvoir réussir à tout prix
quoi alors vous apprenez également le
maniement des armes jusqu'à la
perfection parce que de toute façon tant
que c'est pas parfait vous prenez les
coups de bâton le maître a un bâton de 2
mètres de long et vous tape dessus tant
que c'est pas bien
le soir on se lave à l'eau froide on
dort sur une planche en bois dans un
dortoir sans chauffage et le soir vous
pleurez ah ouais ça c'est sûr
que certaines fois vous avez la
tentation d'abandonner mais là vous
pensez à vos parents et bientôt
Dominique vous rejoignez l'élite
vous arrivez à briser une barre de fer
sur votre crâne oui tout à fait en fait
ce sont des exercices qui se qu'on
appelle le Ying donc le Tigan dur donc
c'est des exercices qui demandent
beaucoup le travail interne donc et
évidemment ça c'est lié à trois choses
donc la préparation physique mentale et
spirituelle là il faut que les trois
éléments soient liés pour pouvoir
arriver à faire ce genre de esprits vous
arrivez à rester à plat ventre sur
quatre lances vous arrivez à l'époque à
pousser un camion avec une lance dont la
lame est pointée sur votre gorge
là vous devenez le premier moine Shaolin
africain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et aujourd'hui Dominique vous développez
des écoles de kung-fu en France en
Afrique les 4000 élèves et puis vous
avez une troupe d'athlètes en spectacle
ça s'appelle Shaolin black and white
l'adresse ça paraît en bas de l'écran
alors on prépare un film sur vous c'est
surtout surtout vous avez été admis au
panthéon du Cameroun comme Roger Milla
[Applaudissements]
c'est de vivant quand vous mettre au
Panthéon c'est pareil en France voilà
alors je peux nous montrer ce que ce que
vous faites
avec plaisir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu